qui est de comprendre ce qui s'est passé
à l'occasion de ces éutes ne pas
seulement avoir un regard qui soit un
regard qui relève de la compétence
direct de la commission des lois à
savoir justice police mais d'aller
beaucoup plus loin dans ce travail et
singulièrement d'avoir aussi un peu un
regard sociologique finalement dès lors
que nous avons auditionné de fait nous
avons auditionné des professeurs
d'université
sociologue beaucoup de grande
diversité de de personnalit nous sommes
allés en déplacement et pas plus tard
que la semaine dernière je regarde
madame Narin puisque nous étions
ensemble à Laval qui é une commune qui a
eu un certain nombre de d'événements
importants aussi pas que il y en a
d'autres bien évidemment on a auditionné
des maires on a auditionné beaucoup de
monde et l'idée d'ailleurs de vous
entendre c'est vous avez évidemment
réalisé des films sur avec en portant un
regard sur les banlieu notamment et
l'intérêt pour nous c'est de croiser les
regards
euh de façon par ce que les choses sont
assez claires pour compreniez bien nous
voulons essayer de nous approcher le
plus possible de la vérité de ce qui
s'est passé des raisons qui ont été
celles qui
ont final servi c'est pas le terme mais
qui ont occasionné les événements du
mois de juin dernier on aura peut-être
une réponse législative pour partie
peut-être pas peut-être une réponse
réglementaire simplement peut-être des
travaux à prolonger sur d'autres pistes
mais via peut-être d'autres commissions
et c'est ça qui nous intéresse notre
rapport sera rendu au mois de mars et
nos travaux se Contin continuent au
cours du mois de février voilà j'ai été
beaucoup trop long donc nous sommes très
heureux de vous accueillir ce matin deux
autres personnalités devaient venir mais
euh j'ose pas dire qu'on a pas de
nouvellees mais c'est un peu ça quand
même mais vous êtes là donc c'est
l'essentiel on va vous laisser la parole
les les collègues poseront sans doute
des questions ensuite je vous indique
que normalement nous sommes retransmis
en direct sur la chaîne publque Sénat et
peut-être même le site internet du Sénat
contenu du retard je mesure pas les les
enjeux techniques mais en tous les cas
vous avez la parole al je sais pas si
vous avez prévu un ordre entre vous deux
ou pas du tout je vais laisser la parole
à mon aîné d'abord alors Monsieur
dufreine Vous AVEZ LA PAROLE
bonjour Merci le le cadet donc il laisse
la parole à îné
ouais merci mesdames et messieurs
monsieur le Président merci de de nous
accueillir je suis un petit peu dans
l'expectative mais j'avoue une belle
expectative je trouve ça formidable
réellement que le Sénat aille sonder les
réalisateurs la culture pour parler de
la commission des lois surtout et et et
en plus la plus belle des commissions
hein la
plus ouais mais je suis déjà venu mais
non mais enfin B la plus importante
enfin bon on va pas faire voilà on a
compris euh je je je voudrais vous dire
d'où d'où je parle il se trouve que en
2007 j'avais réalisé mon premier
documentaire qui s'appelait quand la
France sans bras qui faisait suite aux
émeutes de 2005 et euh au CPE de 2006
c'était un premier travail sur le
maintien de l'ordre et depuis cette date
entre autres choses je travaille
beaucoup sur le maintien de l'ordre euh
et notamment le le maintien de l'ordre
dit répressif puisque il y a le maintien
l'ordre récréatif le maintien fait de la
musique le maintien de l'ordre sportif
les les les matchs et cetera et le
maintien de l'ordre répressif et cetera
et c'est peut-être de cela dont je
pourrais éventuellement vous parler ça
compte pour moi j'ai vécu aussi cette
année à Saint-Denis et donc j'ai une
vision outre périphérique des choses qui
me semblent extrêmement importantes
alors puisque euh tu as parlé de que
j'étais ton aîné je voudrais juste
mettre les choses en place par par
rapport à à un rapport qui date de 2005
mais qui à mon avis aurait pu être écrit
en 2023 par la Direction centrale des
renseignements généraux ce sera pas long
mais ça me semble
capital la France a connu une forme
d'insurrection non organisé avec
l'émergence dans le temps et l'espace
d'une révolte populaire des cités sans
leader et sans proposition de programme
c'est la direction centrale des
renseignements généraux la DCRG qui
n'existe plus on pourra peut-être en
parler qui a publié ce rapport le 2 3
novembre 2005 les policiers y affirmé
aucune manipulation n'a été décelée
permettant d'accréditer la thèse d'un
soulèvement généralisé et organisé ainsi
les islamistes n'auraient joué aucun
rôle dans le déclenchement des violences
et dans leur expansion ils auraient au
contraire eu ouvre les guillemet tout
intérêt à un retour rapide au calme pour
éviter les amalgames les policiers
assurent par ailleurs que ouvrez les
guillemets c'est le rapport des
renseignements généraux c'est pas euh
bah vous avez compris voyez d'où ça
vient les jeunes des cités étaient
habités d'un fort sentiment identitaire
ne reposant pas uniquement sur leur
origine ethnique ou géographique mais
sur leur conditions sociales d'exclus de
la société française les policiers
précisent les jeunes des quartiers
sensibles se sentent pénalisés par leur
pauvreté la couleur de leur peau et leur
nom ceux qui ont saccagé les cités
avaient en commun l'absence de
perspective et d'investissement par le
travail dans la société française la
conclusion les policiers évoquaient en
2005 avec inquiétude à propos des cités
ouvrez les guillemets des getteaux
urbains à caractère ethnique il est à
craindre désormais que tout nouvel
incident Fortui décès d'un jeune
provoque une nouvelle flambée de
violence généralisée c'était donc en
2005 tout était dit il se trouve que
Nicolas Sarkozi va dissoudre les
renseignements généraux pour les mettre
dans ce qu'on appelait la la la dessérie
qui va devenir la
DGSI je sais que vous avez déjà
travaillé sur la la question du du du
renseignement c'est peut-être pas utile
d'en parler ici mais il est quand même
absolument incroyable de se dire qu'à 20
ans d'écart quasiment 18 ans d'écart
tout était déjà dit l'élément
déclencheur est toujours le même la mort
d'un pardon je suis d'accord vous êtes
d'accord non mais je vous dirai après
vas-y ah oui d'accord euh si vous êtes
d'accord c'est c'est c'est c'est
parfait donc il y a toujours un élément
déclencheur dès lors qu'on parle
d'émeutes il est intéressant de voir que
les renseignements généraux parlaient de
soulèvement populairire des quartiers il
est intéressant de voir que les les
acteurs des quartiers pour 2023 parle de
révolte parle de soulèvement et ne parle
ou de colère et ne parl pas d'émeutes
dès lors que l'on parle d'émeutes comme
vous l'avez fait au début qui est le
langage courant en fait qu'est-ce que
l'on fait on pointe uniquement le côté
délictuel et criminel l'émeut et on
dévitalise totalement le message qu'il y
a derrière il s'agit pas de dire est-ce
qu'on est pour ou contre le message mais
je vous remercie de faire en sorte qu'on
puisse écouter qu'il y a des messages
qui sont autre que ce que la doxa
politicomédiatique grosso modo nous a
raconté en 2023 comme en
2005 alors
Monsieur Paron coup là voilà euh bonjour
à toutes et à tous je tiens à remercier
remercier la commission des lois pour
l'organisation de cette commission le
président et toutes les personnes
présentes au sein de cette Assemblée je
sal sal mon confrère David juffreen pour
ses travaux lui ainsi que mes aînés je
suis très respectueux vous voyez de ceux
qui étaient là avant moi pour leurs
travaux en ce qui concerne la question
des violences policières parce que j'ai
réussi à comment dire à comprendre qu'en
fait c'était un fléo qui minait la
société française depuis bien longtemps
bien avant ma naissance donc je vais
faire un retour rapide sur mon parcours
je m'appelle Jarad jiki je suis cinéaste
je viens de la ville de Gren que vous
connaissez peut-être ville
malheureusement comment dire la plus
pauvre de France est connue un peu pour
son côté sulfureux donc voilà j'ai
grandi là-bas euh au dans le quartier de
la Grande Borne et malheureusement euh
le quartier de la Grande Borne et
d'autres quartiers on va dire on fait
face à la police plus que la norme si je
peux dire ça comme ça et malheureusement
les rapports sont souvent conflictuels
euh il y a de la peur il y a de la
défiance et euh ça je l'ai vu depuis euh
l'âge de 10 ans je vais vous raconter
une anecdote un de mes aînés que
j'apprécié beaucoup
euh s'est fait contrôler devant mes yeux
alors que je sortais de l'école avec mes
amis j'avais 10 ans et euh voilà il
était en train de faire la mécanique sur
sa voiture et une patrouille de police
est arrivée et très vite c'est monté
voilà ce qu'on a pu voir avec George
Floyd euh le le le genou sur la sur la
tête les injures le tutoement délibéré
ça j'ai vu ça que ce soit moi ou
d'autres personnes on a vu ça très très
tôt donc c'est très très difficile de
grandir et de se construire avec voilà
ce genre de de situation car il y a
directement sentiment de de défiance et
de peur qui se met en place bref je vais
m'arrêter de ce côté-là mais j'ai grandi
j'ai développé des passions notamment
pour cinéma et en 2015 j'ai réussi à
intégrer euh la féis qui est la
meilleure école de cinéma de de France
voilà euh j'ai réalisé un premier
court-métrage qui voilà dieu merci il a
eu un petit écho et par la suite je me
suis dit j'aimerais bien faire un un
courtmétrage qui serait un peu plus
ambitieux qui serait un peu plus
d'utilité publique sans prétention
aucune et voilà je je me suis tourné euh
vers mes amis vers euh ma vie et vers ce
qui se passait malheureusement
actuellement en France donc on était en
plein dans l'affaire Adama trauré Théo
laka donc je me suis dit bon euh nous
aussi à grininy malheureusement des fois
il y a ce genre de chos qui se
passe dans cette ville donc je vais
faire un film en tout cas un
courtmétrage sur les violences
policières et je dis bien violence
policière et non bavure policière parce
que bavure policière on a signue qu'il y
a une erreur c'est fait une fois deux
fois mais quand c'est constant c'est
systémique voire systématique ça ça
s'appelle des violences des crimes
policier donc je tiens vraiment à à bien
préciser les termes sont importants
quand on les utilise donc je me suis dit
que j'allais faire un film dessus voilà
en fin 2017 et voilà il y a eu un un
petit écho quand même on a été pris à
Cann et on a eu quelques prix en
festival et et cetera bref
euh ce que je veux dire par tout ça
c'est que si on veut comprendre la
question des des violences policières
attention c'est pas il y a un camp les
des gentils et un camp des méchants
d'accord c'est pas c'est pas une
dichotomie il y a du mal des deux côtés
il y a de la délinquence dans les
quartiers ça il faut le dire on va pas
faire le le bisounours mais ce que moi
et d'autres personnes amoureuses de
justice et de paix tout simplement parce
que beaucoup de personnes veulent vivre
en paix en France et ça peut étonner
certains et certaines mais bien
évidemment en banlieu beaucoup de
personnes veulent vivre en paix et
comment on peut y arriver et ben tout
simplement en en respectant ces
personnes en les humanisant euh en quand
un policier par exemple je vais vous
parler de Steve Maya caniko voilà qui
est décédé euh en 2019 lors de la fête
de la musique suite à à une intervention
de police le policier voilà qui a été
mise m en cause euh va être promu euh
chef de la circonscription de police
nationale à Lyon euh quelques jours
avant qu'il passe en procès euh pareil
une ou deux semaines avant Théo luaka à
bobini voilà qui a été violé je dis bien
violé parce que quand on introduit un
objet euh forcé
euh en quelqu'un ça s'appelle un viol
donc quand à la suite de son procès euh
enfin de du jugement des policiers bah
qui l'ont agressé euh on émane du surcil
ce genre de choses font que
malheureusement la la défiance va être
automatique et on peut pas tout de suite
dans les médias avoir confiance on va
pas essentialiser tout le corps policier
bien évidemment moi le premier je suis
tombé sur des policiers qui faisaient
leur métier par vertu par amour et par
souci de de de servir la la population
française quel que soit son origine mais
c'est ces petits excusez-moi du terme
cracha aux familles de victimes et eu à
la population française tout simplement
font que il y a une défiance qui se met
en place et et la synergie elle peut pas
être totale quoi donc j'ai essayé avec
mon court-métrage en m'inspirant bien
évidemment des travaux de mes aînés
l'algée Mathieu kassovit et cetera de de
proposer le pourquoi du comment parfois
dans les banlieux ça peut être
incandescent entre l'institution
policière et et les gens de baneu voilà
merci à vous
merci Monsieur alors y a-t-il des
questions moi j'en ai quelquesunes mais
allez-y alors madame narass
oui merci beaucoup pour C ces propos
introductifs ce qui nous laisse je pense
du temps pour un pour un échange plus
plus précis sur ce qui s'est passé en en
2023 et et par rapport justement à 2005
puisque vous avez commencé monsieur par
parler de de 2005 en 2005 il y avait
c'était quand même plus circonscrit sur
la les il y avait eu moins de de
contagion au niveau national et par
ailleurs le lien direct avec les
événements
euh déclencheur la la la mort des deux
jeunes euh à à clichi euh était était
établi et contesté par personne et ce
que on entend quand même beaucoup euh
depuis le début de nos auditions et dans
nos déplacements c'est et notamment à
travers aussi les témoignages de ceux
qui ont sont passés en comparution
immédiate euh c'est que Naël enfin le
l'événement de déclencheur la mort de
Naël est très peu cité cité plus sur les
par les émetiers en en région parisienne
en île-de-fance mais beaucoup moins
ailleurs et puis il y a quand même eu
une diffusion là qui est quand
même on connaît le rôle des réseaux
sociaux notamment qui qui qui a été
beaucoup plus large et inattendu et y
compris dans des dans des sur des
territoires où on n' pas l'habitude de
voir des émeutes au niveau national euh
et donc je je voudrais comprendre de
votre point de vue un peu cette des
connexions parce qu'on entend aussi on a
aussi vu des médiateurs et ce et qui
donc disent même s'il y a pas de des
sociologues qui disent que même s'il y a
pas eu de de revendication politique
construite par rapport à ce qui s'est
passé sur elle il y a quand même un
clair phénomène d'identification et il y
a on va dire une atmosphère et une et
une colère qui existe et qui peut
expliquer aussi cet embrasement même si
elle n'est pas euh clairement euh
exprimé euh et et donc euh d'une part
plus généralement à à à à vous deux
comment est-ce que vous voyez cette
cette déconnexion qu'il y a avec aussi
c'est vrai il y a eu beaucoup de
comportements qu'on peut qualifier
d'opportuniste euh avec des pillages
très organisés qui étaient clairement
pas juste parce que on mange pas à sa
fin à cause du à cause de l'inflation
hein et de de réduction du pouvoir
d'achat mais qui était aussi une volonté
de per des choses qu'on va pouvoir
revendre avec avec clairement aussi des
lien avec du crime organisé quand même
enfin des bandes et ca donc l'arêvage de
mortier qui était aussi très organisé
tout ça donc il il y a quand même un des
phénomènes un peu complexes peut-être
euh qui qui sont qui sont mis en place
de manière un peu plus euh enfin qu'on a
pas vu en 2005 euh et et je voudrais
comprendre de votre point de vue sur ces
origines sociales euh comment est-ce que
vous expliquez qu'elle soit pas exprimée
clairement mais quel quelles sont quel
quel euh quelles sont pour vous leur
importance et et et et les mécanismes
qu'il y a derrière ça et et aussi le
fait qu'on soit on soit passé dans un
niveau de violence qui est en fait euh
plus élevé avec une volonté vraiment
délibérée là de cibler les policiers de
cibler aussi dans pas mal d'endroits les
bâtiments publics euh et aussi même
souvent des des des endroits qui
profitent à la population euh de manière
beaucoup plus systématique euh et euh et
puis monsieur dufren comme vous avez
aussi travaillé sur les les questions de
de maintien de l'ordre euh je voudais
avoir un petit peu votre votre avis sur
euh sur sur C cette façon qu'on a
peut-être un peu spécifique française de
de gérer le maintien de l'ordre est-ce
que ça est-ce que ça augmente le
désordre finalement euh ou est-ce que
c'est est-ce que donc on doit interroger
ces pratiques de maintien de l'ordre et
euh euh et et pour pour Monsieur
Diara par rapport à cette relation avec
avec la police euh justement quel est
euh euh quel est l'effet euh de de ce
que vous appelez effectivement des des
discriminations et des des et des
comportements violents systémiques que
cette perception là euh à quel quand
dans le les travaux que vous avez fait
pour produire pour pour réaliser vos
films
euh quel est le vraiment euh le le le le
niveau de de de sentiment est-ce que
c'est très très partagé dans dans chez
les jeunes de ces quartiers ou est-ce
que c'est quelque chose qui reste sur
des des populations très restreintes
voilà merci Madame josand puis madame
Floren et puis peut-être monsieur
kerouche et sans doute
moi merci monsieur le Président et et
merci nos intervenants pour leurs propos
introductifs effectivement qui laissent
davantage la place au au au débat mais
euh je je dans ce que ce que vous avez
dit j'ai quelques interrogations et
peut-être quelques euh h euh
rectification à faire parce que on on
est déjà sur sur une un niveau de de
débat qui semble donc laisser entendre
qu'on n'a pas pris en compte le fait
qu'il y a toujours un fait générateur
qui est la mort d'un jeune et dans le
cadre de ces de cette commission des
travaux que nous avons réalisé des
auditions que nous avons faites il a
clairement été dit euh que le le point
de départ très clairement est la mort
d'un d'un jeune simplement euh comment
expliquez-vous le fait que la mort d'un
jeune puisse alors moi je suis sénatrice
des piranis oriental puisse générer dans
certaines villes des émeutes et des
débordements et des manifestations de
violence donc important et dans d'autres
noms je m'explique plus précisément
Perpignan qui est une place en général
de d'meut de violence et de de de
rébellion hein clairement pour
différentes raisons que que vous
connaissez en 2005 ça a été très très
très fort très violent chez nous on a
même été
malheureusement cité un exemple comme
étant un centre névralgique de cette
violence et donc de ces ces difficultés
social qui qui sont souvent
exprimé et comme sousbassement de ces
ces émeutes et et très étrangement en
2023 on a interrogé ici des spécialistes
personne n'a su nous donner la réponse
euh pourquoi en 2023 sur père Pignan ça
n'a pas bougé mais pas bougé du tout
voilà quel est votre regard là-dessus
deuxième chos euh dans dans dans sans
trahir les les secrets de nos auditions
mais il a été aussi clairement dit qu'il
y a eu deux temps dans ces émeutes il y
a eu le moment où on a parlé de cette
mort du jeûne systématiquement comme
étant le l'élément l'événement de
référence pour justifier euh ou ou en
tout cas qui a entraîné hein c'est
peut-être pas le terme justifieré mais
les manifestations de violence et il a
été aussi clairement dit et partagé par
par beaucoup d'observateurs de de de
d'obédience et de niveau d'analyse
différents euh qui a eu un deuxième
temps euh à partir duquel euh les euh on
ne faisait plus référence à la mort de
Naël mais on faisait référence à euh un
tas de d'autres éléments qui peuvent
justifier des manifestations de de de
violence et et et notamment
effectivement des difficultés sociales
mais pas que euh donc euh ça c'est une
c'est la rectification que je voulais
faire parce que c'est important aussi on
a du mal à comprendre ce qui fait qu'à
un moment donné on oublie quasiment la
mort du jeune pour
justifier les les émeutes ou en tout cas
se sentir en adéquation avec un
mouvement de de de
violence là où je voudrais avoir votre
avis c'est vous êtes des professionnels
de
l'image ce qui a été clairement dit
aussi dans le cadre de ces auditions
c'est que le le deuxème notamment moment
pardon a été notamment abondé par le
fait que il y a avait un un culte une
course à à à à à l'image à aux images
choc et et l'influence des réseaux
sociaux a été Poé du doigt comme étant
un élément déterminant puisque les
jeunes faisaient la course à ceux qui
auraient euh le l'image la plus euh la
plus forte qui passerait bon non
seulement en boucle sur les les les
réseaux de de communication et les et
les euh et et les les les groupes euh
privés mais aussi et surtout celui qui
pour pourrait avoir son image sur les
les chaînes d'information et quel est
pour vous qu'est-ce qui justifie donc le
rapport à l'image évidemment on se dit
c'est une notoriété peut-être rechercher
même même de courte durée mais une
notoriété quand même mais mais pourquoi
pourquoi chercher cette ce ces images
choc plutôt que d'être plutôt témoin par
exemple de ce que vous vivez et et et et
de reprendre les propos tels que vous
les exprimez c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont
beaucoup plus justes par rapport à ce
que vous vivez et finalement euh quelle
est votre analyse par rapport au fait
que ces images choquent et cette cette
violence peut être contreproductive par
rapport au message que que que
souhaitent justement transmettre ceux
qui qui sont en en situation peut-être
pas donc d'émeut je j'entends ce que
vous dites mais de de de de rbellion ou
de manifestation d'une d'une colère
voilà merci merci Madame Floren merci
monsieur le Président euh merci beaucoup
Monsieur dufen et Monsieur Diara pour
vosos vos premières interventions euh
évidemment c'est m'intéresse
particulièrement je suis sénatrice des
hautes scène
j'étais député
euh donc de la 4e circonscription des
hautes scènes jusqu'en 2022 qui comprend
la ville de Nanterre et je suis toujours
élu à Suren et et donc particulièrement
intéressé et je vais pas répendre ce qu'
dit mais ma collègue mais effectivement
sur le fait générateur euh comment vous
dire
euh on a vu les choses de près et on a
vu aussi et je vois depuis un certain
nombre d'années le climat de de certains
de ces quartiers euh et on le vit et les
habitants le vivent quotidiennement ce
que je voulais juste faire comme
remarque avoir votre sentiment là-dessus
c'est euh que par exemple à Nanterre il
y a plus de trois programmes de
rénovation urbaine
sur la France il y a eu un rapport he de
la Cour des comptes sur les programmes
de d'en rue il y a des remarques
intéressante dont il faudra qu'on tienne
compte d'ailleurs je pense dans cette
commission d'enquête mais c'est pas rien
c'est énorme c'est c'est c'est des
milliards d'euros les chiffres de 2004 à
2020 et comme vous faites le parallèle
2023 c'est 600 quartiers rénovés 4
millions d'habitants con anné 12
milliards d'euros de l'EN rue et encore
pour 2030 17 12 milliards d'en rue qui
vont être et qui sont programmés donc
moi ma ma remarque c'est euh par av par
rapport à votre intervention
préliminaire euh à quoi ça sert à quoi
ça sert
dans votre monde qui est ce pourquoi
vous êtes là aujourd'hui le monde
culturel est-ce que vous jugez quelle
est la place des associations
culturelles justement dans ces cartes
quel est leur rôle en quoi on peut
l'améliorer si ça ne fonctionne pas
parce que ça c'est un c'est un vrai
sujet par rapport à à ces à ces millions
et et et milliards d'euros sur ces 20
ans qu'est-ce qui fonctionne qu'est-ce
qui ne fonctionne pas notamment dans les
quartiers dans ces associations et
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait améliorer on a
déjà un certain nombre de réponses je
vous le dis par par la Cour des comptes
et au-delà de ça
euh voilà moi je je m'interroge voilà je
je suis une habitante de ces quartiers
euh je connais les habitants de ces
quartiers j'y suis allé
euh je je pense qu'il y a un travail
très sincère et très réel sur le terrain
euh maintenant euh je crois qu'il faut
tenir compte de ce qui s'est passé en
2023 et qu'il a des réponses très
concrète à apporter euh je crains aussi
je vous le dis très sincèrement une
influence grandissante d'un certain
nombre d'associations qui ne rendent pas
service à cette jeunesse et on pourra
éventuellement en reparler je ne veux
pointer aucune d'entre elles
spécifiquement merci FL monsieur
kerouche
oui je vais je vais aller vite en vous
remerciant d'abord de votre de votre
présence
aujourd'hui il y a des sociologues qui
sont qui qui qui sont venus nous voir
qui nous ont fait et proposer leurs
analyses et il y en a une notamment qui
m'a qui qui qui qui qui m'a marqué j'ai
correspondu avec le le chercheur en
question qui m'a renvoyé vers des
travaux comparatifs entre la France et
et l'Allemagne qui dit de manière très
très résumer la chose suivante c'est que
en en Allemagne il y a une capacité
d'insertion plus forte des jeunes issus
de de l'immigration singulièrement dans
les filières industrielles et
que au niveau global en France il y a
une désillusion de plus en plus forte
des descendants d'immigrés dans la
mesure où il y a une promesse il y a une
promesse
d'universalité qui est la promesse
française à travers notamment les
diplômes et que cette promesse étant
sans cesse remise en cause il y a une il
y a une une désillusion et un retrait de
de de de ces jeunes vis-à-vis donc des
des
des institutions parce que les promesses
ne sont pas tenues donc simplement
comment vous percevez comment vous
percevez et mesurez cette désillusion
pas pas c'est pas on vous demande pas
une observation sociologique mais est-ce
que vous confirmez cette cette façon de
voir il s'agit pas là
d'excuser ce qui s'est passé Corine
darassiga l'a dit il y a eu il y a les
il y a le débordement en tant que tel et
il y a tout ce qui se fait à la
périphérie du du débordement qui
relève plutôt de la de la délinquence
que du mouvement du mouvement social les
deux étant la plupart du temps intriqués
mais
sur sur l'ambiance et sur cette cette
cette défiance ou cette promesse pas
tenue par par la République comment vous
jugez la chose
merci merci alors vous avez vous avez la
parole moi je vis simplement préciser
euh on voulait aller à Grigny en en
déplacement
c'était prévu et puis on on nous a fait
dire en tous les cas le mè qu'il avait
pas eu d'événement particuli donc nous
irons à év Courcouronne pour tout vous
dire voilà donc on se déplace partout
j'insiste sur enfin j'insiste je ce qui
est très intéress enfin ce qui ce qui
nous paraît intéressant c'est
qu'effectivement la mort de Naël
constitue évidemment une première
réaction lié aux conditions de celle-ci
sur le territoire de nanter je l' fait
très simple ou très courte c'est même
extrêmement simplifié mais on constate
en tous les cas on nous dit on constate
c'est la constatation elle vient du fait
qu'on nous le
raconte sur le reste du territoire
national plus personne ne
revendique avoir agi pour cette cause là
ou cette situation là et on est dans une
situation semble-t-il d'abord
d'opportunités
incontestablement
de casser les magasins pied dans les
magasins ça c'est la première chose euh
de destruction de bâtiments publics de
de toute nature qui marque une volonté
de contester une forme toutes les formes
d'autorité si je puis dire et que
paradoxalement
euh il y a des réactions dans des
communes et des événements qui ont lieu
alors qu'habituellement elles n'ont pas
lieu et qu'à l'inverse dans des
territoires où habituellement euh ça
bouge grosso modo les les les ce qu'on
appelle les banlieux difficiles moi j'ai
jamais trouvé des mots très précis pour
qualifier les choses mais où ça n'a pas
bougé ou très peu bon et puis enfin il y
a effectivement ce qui caractérise ces
événements c'est la violence extrêmement
forte des émetiers à l'égard de la
police alors quand je dis violence euh
bon il peut y avoir en cas de
manifestation et des choses très viriles
on est d'accord enfin on est d'accord on
constate mais là avec la volonté de
blesser voir de tuer et notamment par
l'usage l'utilisation des fameux
mortiers
d'artifice qui ont été qui ont servi de
on appellerait ça en milieu militaire de
lance de je cherche le nom j'ai oublié
ça m'a passé pardon non non non non
enfin bon peu importe chacun comprendra
bien ce que je veux dire et et ça ça
semble très nouveau plutôt par rapport à
ce qui s'est passé en 2005 où
ENF essentiellement par rapport à 2005
donc votre regard que vous avez porté
par votre caméra sur les événements post
2005 ou plus récemment 2017 pour vous
monsieur Diara est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous feriez la même chose
vous regarderz les choses de la même
manière ou est-ce que vous voyez les
mêmes événements qui sont à l'origine de
C de de ces événements voilà est-ce que
je suis clair je suis pas sûr mais en
tout cas on essaie de
comprendre et puis je voulais vous dire
que sur oui tout à l'heure vous parliez
des renseignements généraux
effectivement mais ce sont les
événements de 2015 qui font que sont
remis en place ce qu'on appelle le
renseignement territorial et finalement
et qui est reconstitué et et qui
aujourd'hui fonctionne voilà ben je sais
pas dans l'ordre que vous voulez
monsieur dufreine
alors je vais essayer de j'ai pris
beaucoup de notes je vais essayer d'être
rapide on a du papier on a du papier
ouais non mais c'est bon je mon ger
maintenant euh alors d'abord je voudrais
quand même vous dire que il faut pas
minimiser 2005 2005 c'est 3 semaines
2005 c'est 80 départements sur 100 c'est
pas exactement ce que vous nous avez dit
c'est l'état d'urgence qui est décrété
par Dominique de Villepin contre
d'ailleurs la vie de Nicolas Sarkozi
état d'urgence qui n'était pas arrivé
depuis 61 en France 1961 en France la
l'Algérie la guerre d'Algérie hein c'est
c'est c'était ça la référence donc il
faut c'est vrai que c'est loin mais il
faut se rappeler qu'en réalité c'était
absolument considérable et toutes les
questions euh auquel on va essayer de
répondre euh en fait elles sont elles se
posaient déjà en 2005 c'est pour ça que
je pense que le le parallèle est à faire
il y a effectivement des distinctions à
à à à mener alors vous vous disiez au
début euh c'était pas tellement contesté
Z desbouna euh si c'était contesté
puisque euh euh on on nous expliquait
queil y avait eu un com violage dans un
cabanon de de de de chantier et que
c'était des des jeunes délincants qui
avaient fui et cetera enfin ça a été
extrêmement extrêmement compliqué
d'avoir la la vérité en revanche il n'y
avait pas l'image il n'y avait pas
l'image de de la centrale électrique de
cliché sous-bois avec la mort de ces
deux jeunes hommes et les brûlures
gravissimes du 3isème qu'on oublie
toujours muitine il y avait pas l'image
donc il y avait un flou autour autour de
ça euh vous disiez euh il y avait plus
de violence en 2023 c'est revenu
plusieurs fois là je je crois que vous
avez raison en effet l'intensité de la
violence d'après les rapports de police
qu'on a pu qu'on a pu voir ou les
témoignages là il y a pas y a a il y a
pas à dire il se trouve que en 2005 la
seule fois où une arme à feu est sortie
c'était à grininy justement je suis
désolé et ça avait fait la Une de Paris
Match mais ça avait été un événement ça
avait été la preuve ça avait été la la
une une de Paris Match on est en 2005 et
en fait la première fois où des
policiers vont essuyer des tirs et c'est
très important de de des mtiers c'est en
2007 à villier- Lebelle et c'est à
partir de là que les policiers dans les
quartiers vont être dotés de
flashball qu'on appellerait aujourd'hui
LBD ça c'est extrêmement important parce
que ça modifie considérablement le
maintien de l'ordre et les rapports
police population et cetera et en effet
en 2023 il semblerait qu'il ait des
armes à feu qui a été brandies qui a été
sortis par par certains émetiers ça
reste extrêmement de la Ve même des
services de renseignement dont vous
parliez très faible par rapport aux
armes dont on nous dit je crois avec
raison qu'elles peuvent circuler dans
certaines cités en fait elles ne sont
pas sorties de la même manière que les
les agriculteurs n'ont pas sorti leur
fusil de chasse
euh récemment c'està qu'il y a au niveau
le niveau de la violence il faut
toujours jour le le le mîre par
rapport comment dire au rapport de force
qui est qui qui existe sur euh
l'identification vous avez dit à
plusieurs reprises en 2005 comme en 2023
les émetiers au départ s'identifie soit
zbouna soit Anael et dans un deuxième
temps non et vous vous interrogez
légitimement sur pourquoi à ce moment-là
pour reprendre votre exppressionion ça
bouge dans un certains quartiers et pas
dans d'autres bah tout simplement parce
que le rapport de force justement il est
il est il est différent c'est-à-dire que
l'étincelle a déclenché un incendie et
que cet incendie le temps de de sa
propagation il est en partie tenu par
les émeotiers il y a plus besoin d'avoir
de slogan pour dire et bien nous nous
exprimons notre colère tout le monde
n'exprime pas une colère on est bien
d'accord mais pourquoi voudriez-vous que
ça s'arrête alors que justement le feu a
pris ce qui m'étonne en fait c'est c'est
c'est de de ne pas comprendre que ce qui
est à l'œuvre c'est quand même une si
vous ne voulez pas mettre de mots
politiques si vous voulez pas dire que
ce sont des slogans ou des
revendications c'est quand même
l'expression d'une exaspération d'un
sentiment
d'injustice c'est pas de l'amusement
alors
opportunité oui il y a des gens qui ont
piliqué des téléphones ou des ou ou des
télévision pour aller les revendre mais
il y a aussi des mères de famille qui
ont volé du papier
toilette du papier
toilette ça vous dit le le le l'état
social de de la dans lequel nous sommes
aller voler du papier toilette qu'est-ce
qui reste
bon alors sur le maintien de l'ORD me
lancez pas là-dessus mais je crois que
vous avez reçu Fabien jaobard et
Sébastien rocher qui sont vraiment
d'éminemment d'éminent d'éminents
spécialistes mais est-ce que ça augmente
le désordre j'ai beaucoup aimé cette
question philosoph phique j'ai fait un
film là-dessus euh ce que l'on peut dire
c'est et on l'a vraiment vu
euh ces derniers jours avec un nouveau
changement de de doctrine de maintien de
l'ordre dès lors que le ministère de
l'Intérieur dit on n'envoie pas des CRS
sur des gens qui souffrent euh il n'y a
quasiment pas de problème de violence et
c'est en gros ce que Fabien jaobard a dû
vous expliquer ou Sébastien rocher avec
la doctrine dite de la désescalade
allemande hein c'est-à-dire que on
revient à un système à l'ancienne qui
était d'ailleurs un petit peu celui de
2005 hein des parce que il faut aussi
rappeler que du côté des émeutiers en
2005 il n'y a pas d'éborniers de mains
arraché de
morts en dehors de Naël et et de
zadbouna enfin en dehors de zadbouna en
2005 il y a pas eu de mort pendant les
émeutes il y en a eu à
Marseille donc le niveau de violence il
est il est il est il est aussi là euh
hop h hop Grini ça j'ai voilà alors
pourquoi certaines villes perpignon pas
perpignon à l'époque de de 2005 il y
avait eu une énigme une énigme totale
qui était Marseille Dee ville de France
pas d'émeutes il y en a eu cette année
enfin en 2023 dans le centre-ville de de
de Marseille mais pas dans les quartiers
on a eu et je crois que personne n' été
capable de bien expliquer pourquoi on a
eu des des explications dis bah à
Marseille dans les quartiers nord on
voit la mer alors on se révolte pas à
Marseille on va pas se révolter parce
que c'est la concurence Paris Marseille
donc on ne va pas objectivement je n'en
sais rien et je pense qu'il faudrait
travailler à Perpignan avec des
travailleurs sociaux pour essayer de
comprendre pourquoi à tel endroit ça a
bougé ou ou pas bougé il y a des
paramètres extrêmement compliqué il peut
y avoir des rivalités entre les
quartiers il peut y avoir des rivalités
entre les villes qui peuvent soit jouer
un caractère d'émulation soit au
contraire de
d'annulation le le le le rôle des images
et ensuite il y aura l'en rue et puis je
je te laisserai je vous laisserai la
parole le rôle des images bah évidemment
il est central mais si nous faisions un
retour en arrière nous parlerions des JT
nous parlerions des JT de France 2 de
TF1 à tel point que nous apprendrions
par la presse estce que on a demandé à
France Télévision qui sera suivi par LCI
et par TF1 à l'époque je suis rédacteur
en chef de iTélé petite chaîne
d'information alors il a rien rien à
voir avec ce ce qu'elle est devenu et je
me souviens que un moment donné le
téléphone a sonné en disant arrêté avec
le palmarès chaque soir arrêté avec le
palmarès du nombre de voitures brûlées
du nombre de commissariat attaqué du
nombre de de d'arrestation et cetera et
donc à l'époque on a CNN qui débarque
qui fait des cartes extraordinaires en
mettant Strasbourg à Varsovie l'Î à
Montpellier enfin c'était je vous assure
je vous invite à aller voir ces cartesl
où on nous expliquait que il n'y avait
pas de raison sociale que c'était
simplement la soif de reconnaissance la
soif de l'image qui animait les
ameetiers qu'elle les anime comme ça
anime toute la société je veux dire
toute la société est traversée par
l'idée que il y a des caméras qu'on veut
être beau à la caméra qu'on veut avoir
le plus de followers possible c'est à
tous les niveaux des ministres aux
émetiers donc c'est un ensemble de la
société qu'on doit interroger par
rapport à ça mais surtout surtout croire
comme l'a dit Emmanuel Macron que les
émeutes c'est les jeux vidéos et les
réseaux sociaux c'est vraiment faire
acte de mon point de vue
d'irresponsabilité et enfin pour la
rénovation urbaine vous avez 1000 fois
raison après 2005 il y a beaucoup
d'argent qui a qui est arrivé dans les
dans les quartiers on a rénové beaucoup
de quartier ça fait même l'objet de de
film bâtiment 5 de de la jelie par
exemple qui raconte la destruction d'un
bâtiment il y a eu effectivement les les
les 12 milliards dont vous parlez euh
c'est beaucoup moins que l'argent qui
est injecté pour les Jeux Olympiques qui
vont durer 3 semaines enfin passons en
effet il y a eu une une rénovation
urbaine et je je pense que mon mon mon
acolyte sera plus précis que moi mais
semble-t-il on a changé les bâtiments on
n' pas changé la vie des gens ça c'est
le premier point et le deuxième
point en juillet 2023 la presse sinroge
qu'est-ce qui se passe pourquoi il y a
ces émeutes et je voudrais juste vous
citer très très très vite de deux
phrases l'une de Jean-Louis borlau pas
la peine de de le présenter qui nous dit
quand ça a commencé à aller mieux au
milieu des années 2010 on a arrêté de
s'occuper des banlieux ce n'était plus
un problème un peu plus bas dans le même
article un ex-préfet de scène
Saint-Denis dont on n' pas le nom mais
on peut deviner assez facilement qui il
est nous dit cette chose extrêmement imp
importante il nous dit en fait une
génération aura été sacrifiée les 15 17
ans c'estàd les émetiers qui constituent
le gros des émetiers sont les oubliés de
la politique de la ville c'est-à-dire
qu'au moment où on a
baissé la politique de rénovation
urbaine d'égalité des chances et cetera
et cetera c'est une génération qui sort
quelques temps plus tard et ça c'est un
ancien préfet de sa sa c'est jean-l
borlau qui le disent
euh moi je vais je vais pas être très
très long parce que beaucoup de choses
ont été dites par Monsieur dufreen avec
lesquels je suis totalement d'accord et
je pense que j'aurais sûrement mis le
point dessus
euh en ce qui concerne les images euh il
est vrai qu'en alliant euh du son et de
l'image on peut influencer et manipuler
beaucoup de personnes ça c'est c'est
évident qu'on le fasse de manière
professionnelle comme Monsieur dufine et
moi via le cinéma ou par les réseaux
sociaux avec tel que TikTok Instagram et
cetera et c'est vrai qu'il y a eu
beaucoup de de de personnes dans la
révolte qu'on été opportunistes qu'on
saccageit des magasins qu'on par la même
occasion fait beaucoup de mal aux
personnes qui tenaientent ces magasin là
mais comme dans tout mouvement comme
dans toute revendication il y a une
minorité malheureusement euh de fraude
si je peux appeler ça comme ça de fraude
d'opportuniste de
euh pour ce coup là des gens qui sont
pas amoureux de justice et c'est une
minorité malheureusement qui fait
beaucoup de bruit parce que parfois on
leur tend le micro et c'est peut-être la
minorité qui intéresse le plus
et et il y a eu beaucoup de bêtises
j'été le premier au fusquer en voyant
certains saccage certaines exactions
qu'on n'accepte pas et qui
malheureusement entachche la mémoire de
Naël euh et de toutes les personnes qui
ont perdu la vie euh via les violences
policières donc oui c'est quelque chose
à dénoncer c'est saccage mais je pense
qu'il est important de recentrer euh la
question sur mais qu'est-ce qui a amené
ces violences en fait la base de du
pourquoi du comment de ces violences bah
c'est une déshumanisation euh de d'une
partie de la population euh de
l'injustice à tout va de la brutalité
policière le fait de considérer
certaines personnes comme des citoyens
de 2e 3e 4e voire 5e zone c'est tout ça
en fait
qui font que voilà on a un cocktail sans
voilà faire de mauvais jeux de mots mais
on a un cockil Molotov en face et à un
moment donné ça explose et et c'est
c'est regrettable parce que encore une
fois sans être redondant beaucoup de
personnes et c'est l'immense majorité
veulent vivre en paix en France et C
violen cela elles sont dénoncées c'est
vrai dans un premier temps par ces
habitants des bonlieux mais ça va
au-delà et la France le monde entier a
vu que ce problème des violences
policières c'est vrai de Prim àord
touche on va dire les population dit
maghrébine noir africaine voilà mais
elle a touché aussi des Caucasiens des
blancs on l'a bien vu avec le mouvement
des gilets jaunes
et avec voilà des mains arrachées des
gens avec hbornier tout ce qui va avec
c'est pour montrer à quel point ce fléo
là il faut le dénoncer il faut le
combattre et ce qui peut en fait les les
les violences policières c'est juste
l'extension de d'unun d'un système qui
est de base très très violent raciste je
vais le dire raciste parfois négrophobe
parfois antisémite islamophobe c'est
tout ça en fait c'est tout ça qui ont
engendrer ce monstre que sont les
violences policières donc c'est
important de de de de parler de ça
en ce qui concerne les rénovations je
vais je vais aborder moins de points
parce que il y a il m'a il m'a mché le
travail et je suis totalement d'accord
en ce qui concerne les rénovations sans
manquer de respect à toutes les
personnes à la jeunesse de ces
rénovations c'est pas en mettant un coup
de peinture que ça y est c'est bon les
gens vont être heureux désolé he si vous
le prenez mal mais faut que ce soit
beaucoup merci il faut que ce soit plus
profond en fait enfin il y a la question
du logement la question du travail la
question de des perspectives
d'émancipation pour ces personnes c'est
tout ça en fait rénover une
façade c'est bien
et il faut saluer le le travail mise en
place par par les villes mais il faut
accentuer le le travail et accompagner
ces personnes plus profondément si je
peux dire ça comme ça parce que la
considéraation elle ne change pas quand
on regarde bien c'est toujours les les
les mêmes problèmes qui reviennent le
logement le travail et
cetera ensuite
euh ce que je voulais
dire les violences policières les
brutalités policières c'est c'est
cyclique en fait c'est périodique c'està
dire il y a des moments où ça va être
calme comme il l'a dit excusez-moi
monsieur
dufine de 2010 à je sais plus quelle
année on va dire c'est c'est plutôt C
puis après ça revient parce
que comme dans dans toute ch il y a il y
a il y a il y a un pic en fait 2005 2007
2023 l'année dernière avec naë il y a il
y a des pics il a il y a des des des des
interrogations de la frustration de la
colère qui font que ça explose
et enfin voilà c'est c'est pas encore
une fois c'est pas par joie que ces
personnes se révoltent vont créer leur
colère dans la rue ou quoi que ce soit
c'est il y a un ralbol qui est partagé
que ça déplaise à à beaucoup de
personnes mais c'est un ralbol qui est
partagé par l'immense majorité des
Français pas que les noirs et les Arabes
et je pense c'est ça le plus important à
retenir c'est que il faut apporter une
solution à cette question des violences
policières comme ça ça permettra de
faire en sorte qu'on sorte un peu de
cette situation de poudrière dans
laquelle on est en France depuis un
moment voilà ce que je peux dire dans
les
médias merci alors qui s'exprimer encore
on n pas répondu à la question monur ah
allez-y allez-y allez-y alors Monsieur
duf j'ai oublié sur la sur la
désillusion est-ce qu'il y aurait donc
si j'ai bien compris une forme de de
désillusion de la part de de certains
citoyens vis-à-vis de la République
c'est ça ce que vous disiez c'est ce que
semble montrer les les études il y a une
différence il y a une différence en tout
cas entre les descendants d'immigrés
allemand en l'espèce les descendants
d'immigrés français d'un côté on a une
intégration je disis pas qu facile
forcément en Allemagne mais qu'elle se
fait dans des moins mauvaises conditions
alors que en France on a une définition
de la République de l'égalité à travers
par exempleaccès à l'école et cetera et
en fait il y a une désillusion par
rapport au message par rapport à ce
message républicain quand on voit sa
situation
réelle alors moi je je vous donnerai que
des que des chiffres qui répondent mais
sur le sentiment sur la désillusion le
dis en chantement et le détachement je
pense que Monsieur Diara sera plus plus
à même que moi j'ai j'ai j'ai je suis
allé chercher les chiffres de l'INC de
2023 c'estàdire au moment des des des
émeutes 1514 quartiers prioritaires de
la politique de la ville le taux de
pauvreté est trois fois plus élevé il
est de 43% que dans le reste des unités
urbaines trois fois plus élevé le taux
de chômage il est de 18,6 %. c'est entre
2 et 3 % trois fois plus que le reste et
surtout surtout les enfants plus de la
moitié des enfants qui vivent vivent en
situation de pauvreté 57 % des enfants
vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté dans
ces quartiers contre 21 % ce qui est
déjà énorme dans le reste de la France
donc comment voulez-vous avoir la
moindre
illusion quand vous vivez dans ces dans
ces
conditions avant même d'avoir des
désillusions pouvez-vous avoir des
illusions je ne connais pas la situation
allemande mais sur la situation
française ça paraît très
clair le séparatisme il est là la
ségrégation elle est là et c'est Linc
qui le
dit
euh pardon allez-y non non allez-y
allez-y et puis OK eu c'est c'est c'est
c'est très difficile de de en fait le la
merci beaucoup ou j'ai une carte là de
c'est très difficile de rêver en tout
cas la la possibilité de rêver chez
certains elle est coupé très tôt moi euh
des 10 ans ça a été compliqué de de de
pouvoir croire aveuglément en
l'institution qui est la police et et la
France en règle générale mais bien
évidemment de part ma famille et les
gens qui étaient qui sont toujours
autour de moi on on a espoir de de
pouvoir vivre comme il se doit comme
tout le monde même si
voilà le racisme sera toujours là il y
aura toujours des problématiques mais
euh il y aura toujours moyen de de de de
viser une vie meilleure voilà mais puis
il faut que je donne suite à mon prénom
qui dans les langues moningues veut dire
espoir donc si je suis défétiste c'est
pas je ça va pas être possible mais
c'est vrai que pour certains et
certaines la la la la la possibilité de
croire en en les institutions elle est
couper très tôt donc voilà pourquoi il y
a ce sentiment de défiance et ce
sentiment de de rejet et et c'est là
comme l'a dit monsieur dufen qui a le le
vrai séparatisme en fait et c'est la
base de une des bases en tout cas de de
certaines
problématique merci alors madame Mercier
m' demander la parole oui merci monsieur
le Président je je partage ce que vous
dites à la base c'est l'éducation
comment élever nos enfants élever nos
jeunes dans l'amour de cette république
mais c'est vrai qu'on peut on a des
prismes différents mais moi il y a
quelque chose que je n'arrive pas à
comprendre si je prends le département
de
sonellloire la ville de ons surs la
grosse ville avec vraiment des quartiers
prioritaires il n'y a absolument rien nu
vous descendez de 60 km à Macon il y a
eu des dégâts considérables des émeutes
vous remontez au nord dans le bassin
minier des dégâts considérables j'ai
auditionné l'équipe municipale ils
étaient en pleur ils allaient dans les
quartiers la médiathèque a été en feu et
personne ne comprend pourquoi en fait
c'est ça pourquoi la précarité et
malheureusement elle est égale partout
dans ces trois pôles que j'ai vient de
vous citer pourquoi deux pôles ont été
vraiment l'objet de violence inouie et
pourquoi pas la ville de
chalonurs merci euh je prends la main
cette fois-ci euh mais moi je pense tout
simplement madame que le rapport entre
la police et les habitants n'est pas le
même partout en fait même s'il y a des
quartiers dans votre ville
euh la brutalité policière bref les les
les relations qu'on euh les personnes
habitants dans les quartiers que vous
avez cité et par exemple grenny ou nan
c'est pas c'est pas du tout les mêmes
moi je suis persuadé que ça peut être
l'explication du pourquoi du comment ça
n'a pas été
incandescent dans dans dans certains
endroits et il faut s'en réjouir en fait
moi je suis content vraiment je euh faut
pas qu'il ait tout le temps des
problèmes quoi c'est c'est c'est c'est
très bien de de de de se réjouir de ça
et et peut-être de de s'inspirer de ces
endroits et savoir bah com comment le
dialogue est instauré la confiance et
tout ce qui va avec quoi moi je pense
c'est pour ça que parfois dans certains
endroit c'est le braser et dans d'autres
noms
voilà merci est-ce que s'il y a pas
d'autre prise de parole est-ce
que on on peut dire c'est une question
que ce que vous constatez post 2005 ce
que vous avez dit tout à l'heure
finalement euh n'a pas varié comme vous
avez lu le le rapport tout à l'heure
mais que par contre
l'intensité euh de la violence au sens
large du terme là par contre a nettement
progressé et et et enfin moi je suis
convaincu de ça la question est de
savoir le pourquoi est-ce que vous
l'expliquez notamment par le fait que
les gens ou les les habitants de
certains quartiers ou ou pas seulement
des quartiers d'ailleurs parce que faut
pas faire une généralité sur les
quartiers on vient de le voir la
situation personnelle et le la
difficulté individuelle ou collective
d'une partie de la population fait que
euh l'espoir est pas là quoi pour faire
pour utiliser un très grand mot l'espoir
est pas là et que du coup ben la révolte
est d'autant plus
forte je je oui je je suis absolument
convaincu que le l'intensité de la
révolte et indexé sur l'intensité du du
désespoir ça me semble ça me semble
évident mais il y a quelque chose
d'important c'est que les quartiers ont
de la mémoire les émetiers pas forcément
puisque la plupart n'étaient pas né en
2005 donc voilà et même s'ils parlent de
leur grands frères ce serait presque
leur père quasiment mais n'empêche que
ils ont de la mémoire et cette mémoire
c'est quoi c'est un ministre monsieur
borlot qui
démissionne parce qu'il dit dit moi on
me donne pas les moyens euh parce que je
vous ai donné les chiffres sociaux et de
travail et cetera je veux dire il c'est
c'est c'est un moment d'exaspération qui
est extrêmement fort et par ailleurs on
a aussi vu une police beaucoup plus
violente qu'en 2005 on a vu des services
de police qui n'ont rien à faire
eux-mêmes le disent à mot caché dans le
monde et et autres n'ont rien à faire
dans le dans le dans le maintien de
l'ordre ce sont très très mal comporté
je pense notamment au raid et au GIGN à
Marseille c'est eux qui ont provoqué des
des des morts et
blessés il y a une intensité policière
extrêmement forte qu'on avait pas connu
en
2005 pour pour pour faire des émeutes
faut être deux en fait c'est comme les
manifestations et il faut vraiment avoir
en tête me semble-t-il enin tous les
travaux sociologiques dignes de ce
nom démontrent dans une démocratie et et
dans un moment qui n'est pas un moment
révolutionnaire et ça n'est pas un
moment révolutionnaire c'est l'État qui
détermine le niveau de violence on en a
eu un exemple très clair avec les les
les agriculteurs il y a 10 jours qu'on
avait pas vu depuis 20
ans donc ce serait ça ma réponse je ne
crois pas que ce soit que les jeunes
soient plus violents que les armes à feu
soient plus plus accessibl elles sont
quasiment pas sorties et cetera je crois
que c'est plus sur les deux raisons que
je vous ai donné euh monsieur di oui
après je je vous laisse reprendre la
main mais et je
rajouteraiis Internet les réseaux
sociaux vraiment ça a été le vecteur euh
aussi de de euh de l'escalade des deux
côtés hein que soit des émetiers des des
des révoltés et de la police aussi quand
on voit euh en manifestation ou lors
d'une intervention policière l'intensité
euh des répressions bon euh le soir même
ou le lendemain quand les révoltés
répondent ils ont envie de répondre face
à à ce qui a été proposé en face et
vice-versa en fait donc c'est vrai que
les réseaux sociaux Internet a été un
vecteur pour moi des deux côtés voilà
monsieur dufreen vous avez le mot de la
fin écoutez ceux qui ont eu des
déclarations sédiicieuses ceux qui ont
eu des déclarations guerrières ce sont
certains syndicats de police
rappelez-vous le communiqué euh qui a
suivi euh le la mise en détention du
tueur présumé enfin du du meurtrier
présumé de de de naë
euh communiqué
sédiicieux notamment d'alliance mais pas
seulement de ce qu'on appelle le bloc
syndical et communiqué qui n'a pas été
dénoncé comme il aurait dû par le
ministre de l'Intérieur et là alors moi
mon mon prénom c'est pas espoir alors je
je vais je je vais être un peu un peu
désespéré c'est-à-dire que si on laisse
les syndicats de police prendre le
pouvoir sur le pouvoir si on laisse les
identitaires de tout bord prendre le
pouvoir sur les quartiers je pense
notamment aux descentes de l'extrême
droite à crépole euh si on laisse ceci
alors dans Comment à lon bien sûr mais
là à crpool parce que c'est quelque
chose qui qui était un peu de cet ordre
là c'était un peu comme une une revanche
euh fasciste sur sur sur sur les émeutes
il y avait il y avait quelque chose de
cet
ordre-là si les institutions ne prennent
pas
de ce qui est en train de se passer
alors en
2030 je serai pas là pour vous dire 2023
c'est comme 2005 2030 c'est comme 2023
je veux dire là il y a quelque chose
d'extrêmement important
et me semble-t-il la base c'est le
social c'est le travail alors évidemment
ça coûte plus cher évidemment c'est
moins comment diraisje moins
démonstratif que de dire il faut plus de
bleu dans la rue mais c'est infiniment
plus profond
merci messieur merci de votre présence
ce matin on renouvelle nos excuses pour
le retard du début de cette audition et
puis merci aux collègues qui sont restés
jusqu'au bout et bien écoutez euh nous
rendrons le rapport au mois de mars
évidemment quand la Commission en aura
débattu il vous sera adressé merci merci
beaucoup merci à vous merci La Réunion a
suspendu cher colè